foreign
what's up you guys it's Monday yep and
you know what that means it means I've
sobered up
good one Tom I told you that Gotta Have
comedic timing on this [ __ ] I
just come out with that [ __ ] I wasn't
prepared for that I just did it hold on
hold on well here's the thing though
it's like we watched this uh episode
last night we've seen this episode like
a bunch of times this is a really good
one
um and you were watching it like
initially like I think that you know
because we were making jokes about it
and stuff but then like toward the end
of it yeah he was like laying there like
that I couldn't really like see his face
when I thought he was awake and I
thought he was watching but then
but then like at the end of like after
it was over like I asked him a question
like oh did you reset my clock or
something like that because it was
Daylight Savings Time Yeah and uh he
didn't answer yeah I figured it out but
uh he didn't answer and then I was like
looking and I was like that [ __ ]
fell he just fell asleep like sitting up
like that and I was like okay well you
see all the time at the end of the
tombstone review I'm [ __ ] faded as
[ __ ] man yeah everybody said that too
I'm trying to [ __ ] trying to [ __ ]
molest Jenny live on camera I know she's
like he's like crawling all over me and
I'm just like sitting there going I
couldn't um yeah
and then we just go in the other room to
do the review and [ __ ] and I [ __ ]
cozed it up and talked some [ __ ] and
laughed at it and I guess I [ __ ]
dozed off but I've seen that [ __ ] a
million times and then the weird thing
about it too is that that you fell
asleep and then I was like okay it's
over I guess he fell asleep and then I
got up like for like five minutes I went
to the bathroom and then I went and got
like a drink of water and then I came
back in the room and he wasn't there
yeah I thought like he was in the shower
taking out the garbage or something like
that so I just like sat down how to
watch some videos and then I started
watching like a like a zombie movie I
don't know what I'm talking about later
and it's like I don't know how I got it
and then I looked to the man cave and he
was like yeah yeah
how do you remember getting up I don't
know how I got in there you tried woke
up in the next morning it was the next
morning yeah that's the thing I was like
and you fell asleep it was early I mean
you fell asleep at like 8 30 yeah or
something like that yeah I think it was
like 8 30. it was open like not even
nine o'clock yeah if I can
Amy was like I'm gonna watch you go I'm
gonna watch you go okay it says no I'm
right I mean I [ __ ] pop that's what
they always say I popped a wheelie on
the way out of there why are you doing
[ __ ] like that I feel good
thing the cops weren't there yeah a good
thing yeah like I said you don't call me
from jail I'd have been like you know I
just do it sounds like a you problems
I'll just do my time I'll be out of
there in a couple days
okay
you'll know
I'll call in
did uh yeah I'm locked up
I'll be like why am I not surprised this
is my not surprised yes yeah don't give
me a court date I'll be out of here in
about 12 hours
he's just so casual about it it would be
the first time
true uh Danny rolling said the only
problem I have with this episode is how
did the drug dealers ghost end up
haunting the home spoiler alert uh as
well as as well without actually dying
there well see that's the thing they
were very very vague
about uh about this like murder
supposedly to happen
so you know uh and we'll get into that
Daniel Rowling also said the husband of
this episode sounded like Sylvester cat
and Daffy Duck from Looney Tunes when he
talked just saying he did a tad he did a
tad yeah he I think he was in another
episode at least one other episode he
looked kind of familiar I don't know if
he just looked familiar because I've
seen this one a bunch of times or if I I
thought I remembered seeing him from
another one they all start to blend they
do the the classics you have to remind
me because we've seen them I sat down I
went wait which one was this again and I
was like dude we just watched it last
night and I was like yeah they're all
kind and she goes the drug dealer in the
bathtub oh yeah oh yeah yeah that one
yeah we just watched it last night and I
watched it again today like to make
notes about it right so you know yeah I
mean I probably wouldn't need to
necessarily but it's like I like to kind
of just have something to refer to it's
a pretty good episode it is a good
episode I mean there's like uh you know
there's [ __ ] uh ghosts in it like
apparitions like people actually saw
apparitions yeah so you don't know how
legit it is
um yeah not I couldn't find like hardly
any outside info on this so I'm you know
now before we get into this I got a
timer running because I'm I'm cooking
Carnitas downstairs
so that timer is going to probably go
off in about 15 minutes 45 minutes I'm
gonna go down there and release the
pressure on the pressure cooker
Under Pressure well okay yeah yeah yeah
I was thinking a different song but yeah
yeah
then I'll be back up so if you hear that
that alarm going off tell me okay I'll
go ahead and get it but so that's what
I'm telling them to tell me when that
alarm goes off yeah like you're not yeah
like I'm not gonna hear it you're
probably that's some artistic [ __ ] there
man is it yeah I'm not sure that's the
word that I would have used it's just
[ __ ] very very interactive it's
interactive no it's probably the words
you want yeah mango says uh I finally
saw a barbarian today at the cinema fun
movie now I can watch your review yeah I
mean I didn't
spoil anything
um but like I said it's better it's one
of those movies where it's better to go
into where you don't know anything about
it because I didn't know anything about
it like going in to see it and it was
like way better like that but but I
didn't spoil anything in the review but
you know
and let's see oh it says uh he all said
I did work out where it was going after
the end of the First Act though that I
said I still really enjoyed it yeah I
really really liked uh Barbarian I know
that some people really really didn't
like it but that seems like the minority
opinion though because there's always
going to be some people like those
dumbest thing ever but um it seemed like
most people really liked it I really
liked it I thought it was pretty [ __ ]
great
but yeah so um I don't know do you want
to get started talking about the yeah
episode or yeah because we got you got
Carnitas in the crock pot yeah Carnitas
in the crock pot
I don't know that sounds like the title
of something
I don't know what he's got to release
the pressure yeah turn on release the
pressure and it'd be all right then I'll
go down and I'll Brown them later
yeah what's you gonna do with it
Brown I'm gonna Brown I'm in a um no I
mean what's like the end goal of the
like are we gonna make like tacos
and make burritos whatever you want how
come you got two tablets in here what's
that about because that one's got I got
two tablets here because one's got the
timer I'm a very complicated
on this one but it wouldn't be as cool
see okay so you need to have like two
tablets going yeah let's go
I got two tablets
that's the [ __ ] yeah yeah it's like
having two watches
you're really the [ __ ] two different
times though well I must be like back in
the day yeah
I must be like even more of the [ __ ]
because I have like three computers like
right in here I've got a laptop there I
got a laptop there and I got a desktop
there like they're all for different
things it's like headquarters in NASA it
is it's again very very complicated man
when I was a kid I would have thought
this was some [ __ ] out of sci-fi movie
out of the Sci-Fi it is it would have
been like in a Sci-Fi movie it's like
better than this like I'm in the future
yeah yeah
they didn't even predict any of that
[ __ ] when [ __ ] back in the 90s no
that's what I mean
early 90s now I wouldn't even uh late to
the late 80s no I was [ __ ] you were
you were tripping touch screen
video on a thing that was flat that you
could carry around didn't weigh anything
yeah you could Wireless you could take
it anywhere no you're tripping watch
porn wherever you want [ __ ] no
that's a fantasy you're gonna go down to
the dam [ __ ] porn theater and [ __ ]
jerking with [ __ ] whole bunch of
strangers in there sticky ass floors and
[ __ ] that's how they did it back in the
day Brody they were hardcore
or they just didn't really have a choice
they had no choice man you know what I
mean you know the [ __ ] are
peeking at each other probably yeah how
can you not [ __ ] I mean I was but
that might have been part of the whole
like a girlfriend
have her give your hand
then people really be peeking at you
because they're like oh an actual woman
in here yeah she's helping out the dude
next to her
like turn it like turning butter too
yeah and you're like what are you doing
over there yeah yeah
why does this always end up Oliver I
don't know man no matter what the topic
is we always end up either talking about
porn or food
it's you know
I'm a bad influence Ben says love those
owl glasses thank you very much I picked
them yeah these are new Tom bars they're
like cat glasses a little Catwoman yeah
like Catwoman's goggles I wasn't sure if
I would like them or not but I I do
actually I'm getting [ __ ] private
messages [ __ ] Patrick says yeah me
and my girlfriend like him on her they
they look really youthful on her
yeah I thought they were cute they make
my big old head look smaller
it softens your features it softens your
features yeah yeah it looks cute
kind of a retro that those would look
good with your goth outfits the the big
round ones man would look really cool
with uh
uh out on out in the club those are the
cute would you have the right makeup
Motif yeah yeah try those on for side
show well I haven't seen him with I
haven't seen him yes we did this
yesterday I haven't seen him with that
wig
you didn't have a wig
no yesterday I didn't
yeah see I can't see because that's cute
these aren't reading I think that's cute
you guys can put it in the comments
section I think that's a [ __ ] cute
guys I think it I think it like I said I
feel like I got transported back to the
1970s I might be like a [ __ ] total
[ __ ] or anything but I got real good
taste like I could dress women I could
pick out all kinds you might be a total
ass oh that's all I ask you might buy a
[ __ ] man but I could be a fashion
consultant for any woman I go yeah no no
this looks good put this I'd have made a
[ __ ] great [ __ ] drag queen or
something man I [ __ ] dress myself but
hey it's not too late I could dress my
no
[Laughter]
if if dudes had women's clothing that's
all they had to choose from I'd be a
[ __ ] fantastic dresser it's it's easy
to shop for women they got so many
selections it's it's a dudes and these
guys will tell you they just don't give
you any [ __ ] selection no they don't
there's no these clothes are like really
really [ __ ] suck man like I said I
think that's probably why I gotta like
goth and punk and stuff like that
because at least those dudes like wore
interesting [ __ ] yeah it's all the
[ __ ] same generic [ __ ] and if you
don't have a [ __ ] decent build you're
gonna look like [ __ ] in it which is kind
of the same for some women too
like when you're trying to buy [ __ ]
lingerie for a woman you know they're
showing you this [ __ ] thing in a
lingerie model she's a [ __ ] 10. okay
if your girlfriend's a seven or an eight
she's not gonna look the same in that
yeah well you know you're not buying the
you're not buying the underwear you're
buying that girl's ass in the photo yeah
that's what I mean and you just keep
hoping you're hoping that it's like this
you know six dollar pair of underwear
will make my girlfriend's ass look like
that's that's not how though once I got
jacked everything started fitting me a
lot better and I realized that [ __ ]
no I could buy a [ __ ] six dollar pair
of shirt and look pretty good in it and
not back in the day
when it was all [ __ ] belly meat
belly meat belly that also sounds like a
title yeah barely me yeah we got to get
to this [ __ ] case man I can't tell
the teachers people how to dress well no
one asked you to I know I push down and
I get pushed and it's a bad habit
Hugo says by the way Jenny I watched
clown after you mentioned it it was
fresh and original yeah it wasn't good I
was like really surprised by how good
that movie was like I said talk to him
I'm always like a fan of movies that
where like clown monsters eat children
yeah you know what I mean that was a
good one it was a good one yeah it was
like really really gross and like yeah I
really enjoyed it it was something kind
of strangely believable about it you
could put yourself in that dude's
situation yeah if you put that thing on
you couldn't get it off and it was taken
over it was like something
oh man was he trying to cut it off I
think he tried to cut it off and
everything there's just no way no way to
get it off of well I remember the one
part that made me like really
uncomfortable was like at first when he
was trying to like take off the nose and
like wasn't his wife trying to do it
because she was like a dental hygienist
or something like it's been a couple
years since I've seen it but I remember
she had like the tools like the dental
tools yeah she was trying to like pry
the nose off and like the whole time I
was like
I gotta see it again I think it might be
on 2B you could I mean I just thought
like that's why I thought of it because
I saw it like uh on a streaming service
the other day yeah uh somebody said that
you should grow a beard like the drug
dealer in this episode
I can't what does this beard look like
it was pretty no I mean that was like a
pretty straggly looking beard it when it
wasn't a mustache either right there was
it well it was just like I thought it
was just a beard I'm just gonna stay
with the Mig the merciless [ __ ] uh
beard the kitty milk the kitty milk
yeah they're trying to give me each
other again yeah you little kitty milk
that's what that's that's what Big John
told me
Ben says one of my friends did his
Halloween movie challenge one horror
movie every day in October themed on
clowns so he watched a clown horror
movie every day for a month holy crap
and I bet that I mean it'd be pretty
easy to find that many because there's
so many [ __ ] clown horror movies I
remember we saw one the other day
remember that was like well it wasn't
the other day it was probably like a
year or two ago but it was about like a
clown themed
Hotel do you remember that yeah it
wasn't good like I really liked I the
only thing I was like I wonder if that's
like a real clown Hotel because that's
actually pretty cool
um because I was like I can't see that
this movie had enough budget to like
actually build that so maybe that's a
real place which I don't know why the
[ __ ] anyone would ever stay there but
it's like kind of neat anyway but other
than that like it was kind of a terrible
movie I don't even remember what
happened and it was probably just like a
slasher
uh Danny said it was like a triangle
looking beard
uh because I want any kind of long hair
facial hair I don't I don't like
anything long I like [ __ ] short and
[ __ ] real trim I don't like anything
long yeah slasher Fred said one of these
days you should do a discussion or a few
of your favorite Scooby-Doo Where Are
You episodes
you know that might not be a bad idea I
used to really like that chair when I
was growing up yeah it was so long ago
yeah but they have them all on like I
said they're on I think they're on 2B
they're on um I saw them on
Plex maybe or Roku or something I didn't
like those when I was a kid I thought
they were talking down to me I like
Johnny Quest a lot better well Johnny
Quest what's good too Johnny question
maybe we should do like a favorite like
creepy cartoons like scary because I
kind of did a little bit thing like that
on my scarce Salon Channel and I'm gonna
do more of those like because I like the
like those creepy cartoon type things
but yeah
um Amanda says hey Tom and Jenny another
classic clown film is killer clowns from
outer space we might have reviewed that
we reviewed that right we saw it I'm
pretty sure that we reviewed them that's
pretty good movie it's a lot of fun my
favorite part about that is the set
design I mean they clearly spent a lot
of time and effort and I liked all the
detail about it you know what I mean
like all the stuff with the cotton candy
cocoons and all that kind of stuff like
it was really really creative I liked
that
um Ben says use the birdamic shock and
Terror method and just shoot your movie
around real buildings with bystanders as
extras yeah I mean you know
for demic was a masterpiece of [ __ ]
garbage
really [ __ ] hilarious I mean yeah
that was like that guy that makes that
makes those movies because he's made
more than one he hasn't just made bird
damage he made one called replicas yeah
he made one called he made like a
romance movie that was like kind of
Supernatural what the [ __ ] was the name
of that the Julie and something or I
don't remember yeah I saw it on our riff
tracks but it's like that dude it's like
it's sad because he seems like such a
nice man but no idea but he really yeah
he it almost seems like he's like I said
he's like an alien in a human suit yeah
he doesn't know
it's like no it's not Neil Breen
although his movies are funny too yeah
James Nyon James Nyan that's that guy's
name yeah Neil Breen is basically cast
himself as God or Superman in every one
of his [ __ ] movies the object of
every [ __ ] uh uh white girl half his
age is desire yeah yeah he's a trip
which he's a trip and it doesn't [ __ ]
work all right
the other guy knew him the noogan guy
um he's very confused on the mating
rituals of of white teenagers he he's
not really sure how that's done
uh
it's basically about sitting on people's
laps cross you know Crossways and
straddling people there's a lot of that
in it and that you can just see a girl
on the street and follow her home and
knock on her door and say I look I saw
you and hey let's go out yeah that's not
that's not yeah ever how that's going to
work no get the [ __ ] off my doorstep
they get amazed which I don't think he
really had a a dating experience
coming up not in the Western World
Anthony said do you think you'll be
reviewing cool as ice the Vanilla Ice
movie
um oh that's a piece of [ __ ] wow yeah I
I kind of I watched it on Rift tracks
I've seen it yeah um oh man man that is
one of the cringiest movies I've ever
seen I was just like embarrassed for
everyone involved I mean roof tracks
made it funny but because it was just so
I mean it was it was such an easy target
really but yeah that's easily one of the
most inventing cool out of nothing
embarrassing yeah embarrassing things
that I've ever seen yeah oh my God
that's one of the reasons like [ __ ] like
that is one of the reasons that I just
couldn't hang with the 90s I just had
the artificial no street cred zero zero
just totally artificial
yeah it's what you do when you try to
make a wrapper using the same method as
they as the creation of the band Menudo
basically basically what they do
okay just instant rap stars although I
think a lot of the other ones are that
too though they just get a Dude that
[ __ ] looks tougher
I think yeah and can at least like do I
mean yeah I don't know like I said that
was just like seriously it was Prince
worthy yeah like even watching it on
riff tracks I was like the whole time I
was like you know that you know that
like contact embarrassment that you get
like I had that like the whole time I
believe most of the rep most of the
modern rap industry is fake as [ __ ] yeah
corporate is [ __ ]
it may come up out of nothing another
kind of disposable like they're gone you
know they don't last long a lot of them
Ben says uh Neil Breen cinematography is
amazing it's almost all shot Out
outdoors because they can't get
permission to use the inside of
buildings presumably because they don't
have any insurance or permits yeah
that's probably exactly why probably
exactly why
so since we're all here kind of to talk
about the haunting the apartment which
is the one that Danny recommended and
like actually this was one that was on
my list anyway because this is a good
episode and I want to talk about this
this is season four episode four
so as I said don't get like too excited
because I didn't find like too much
outside information on this like some of
the cases you know like the person wrote
a book or you know it was featured on
other shows or anything like that as far
as I could determine uh this is pretty
much a one and done like I didn't really
see the story told
elsewhere
so uh so I don't know I don't know how
legit it was at least like the people on
there like use their real names and [ __ ]
like that
so we're following a pair of newlyweds
and their names are Bill and Marissa
Spencer although Marissa her nickname is
icy and that's pretty much what she's
known as like through the whole entire
thing
so this takes place in Seattle and
starts out like in uh around October of
2004. so I said at this point uh they
had been married for like a month or two
or something like that both of them are
still uh college students and they said
prior to this they had both lived in the
University District I don't know if it
was student housing or they just lived
in that area or whatever but they were
kind of looking for something like in a
more quieter more family oriented
neighborhood because they said you know
they weren't really going out like
partying like a lot of the other
students were and it was kind of noisy
and blah blah so they were looking for
something in a quieter area
so apparently like icy is working toward
a master's degree in mental health and
Bill is studying for his bachelor's and
also like works nights as a contractor
they said for like for a courier company
so I don't know UPS or I don't know what
it is
so they find an apartment in the
newspaper that seems like the ideal
situation
when they get there there's kind of like
they just said there was like a pile of
debris out front you know
um but they're like oh well the location
is like completely perfect it's very
park-like it's very safe it's kind of
like they said it was like just like a
real like right outside of Seattle like
a really nice quaint neighborhood like a
lot of the kind of like little Arty
walking neighborhoods kind of thing
so the property manager comes out and
says well the reason all this [ __ ] is
here is because they're renovating the
inside of the apartment like hence all
of this stuff here
all she said and I just knowing what
what they're uh positing happened in
there she's basically oh well the Last
Tenant
um left in a hurry
and uh the building owner kind of like
left it a little bit of a mess in there
so whoever the building owner was
thought it would be better just like
completely like rip everything out and
like completely revamp the whole
apartment
so she's basically like so if you move
in like you'll get essentially like a
brand new apartment because they're
replacing everything
um and she's like and the price is like
really reasonable so they were just like
super jazz
now so once they get inside like IC is
super excited she's like this is
completely perfect it's like it's in our
budget and everything is wonderful like
good location and everything but Bill
interestingly and again ironically
considering what happens later on in the
episode he kind of feels like a little
bit uneasy though he couldn't really he
said he couldn't really say like why he
said that it just didn't seem like right
in there like it didn't feel right in
there but he thought that it would be
stupid to turn down such an awesome
place just because you know he felt
funny and everything like that so he
kind of like pretends to be all enthused
and they move in a week later
now
um icy actually ends up spending a lot
more time alone in the um apartment
because she's just like in college so
she goes there after class and um but it
seems like Bill is not there much
because he's in class and then like at
night he works so he doesn't come home
until later on so he's not in the
apartment as much so icy is in there
like by herself a lot
so she said when she was in there kind
of like setting everything out at first
she's like she started to feel like
um like she wasn't alone there was
somebody else in there and she said like
it felt like really eerie but you know
as they usually do at first they always
try to like write it off it's like oh
you know I'm stressed out because we've
just moved and it's like you know all
these finals and blah blah blah so she's
like oh I'm sure it's just my
imagination
so a few days go by and she's kind of
trying to not think about it too much
um one night
okay hold on oh the the thing went off
yeah anyway
one night
um this doesn't really this isn't like
super relevant but
bill says that he's taking icy out for
the night and she's like oh we can't
really afford a restaurant and blah blah
but then he ends up like taking her like
out in the mountains like on some kind
of picnic or something like that and I
was just kind of like okay
um I kind of feel like this was like a
good story but you could definitely tell
that
um that there wasn't enough detail in
this like to fill out a whole episode
maybe so they were kind of like filling
in some other things
so the morning after they have this
little
picnic or whatever
um they said like for the first time
since they moved in they don't have I
guess it's like a weekend so they don't
have anything like
um planned or anything like that like
there are any classes or they don't have
work or they are they're all done moving
in it's just the first alarm oh the
first alarm went off I'm gonna sit for
another half hour
that went that went off already yeah
that's what that was yeah because
there's an alarm down there I just
wasn't pot
but then there's this alarm which is it
has to sit 30 minutes and then I release
the pressure oh okay right that's the
thing it's right yeah so no it's fine
okay
yeah because I was like I didn't think
that much time had gone by
no good head yeah I was gonna say it's
only been like 29 minutes or something
like that that's why I wasn't ready I
wasn't ready
um but yeah so let's see okay so they
don't really have anything planned for
this particular day so bill is up just
kind of like sitting at The Breakfast
Table you know having coffee like
reading the paper whatever the [ __ ]
um and icy is still asleep and Bill is
sitting there at the table and sees like
a shadow like what seems like a shadow
of a person like passing by the window
but like outside
um and this kind of like creeps him out
I'm guessing like the way that they had
it because I'm sure like the apartment
that they showed in the episode is not
the actual apartment but the way they
showed it I guess it wouldn't be that
weird if somebody like walked right in
front of your window like that but it
would be like a little bit weird because
they're the way they had it laid out
there wouldn't really any be any reason
for anybody to walk in front of your
window like that because it wasn't like
you had to walk by it like to get
someplace else but at any rate he said
that he saw somebody out there and it
like creeped him out but he said it was
daytime and so he wasn't really all that
concerned about it again so he just kind
of like wrote it off
so a month later they're finally kind of
like settled in uh icy is kind of trying
to concentrate on our school work like I
said finals and blah blah but she said
she's in the apartment again like by
herself one night and she's in the
bedroom studying
and then she hears stuff in the
apartment like it almost sounds like the
door closing and then like footsteps so
she thinks that bill has come home early
so she's like calling out to him
um but then like there's no answer and
then she said that she looked up
and standing in the doorway of the
bedroom there was like a guy like an
apparition like standing there
what's the matter Polk
it says she doesn't like the fan what do
you want me to do about it
it's telling me that the Fan's on yeah I
know the fans daddy the Fan's on yeah I
don't like it yeah
I don't like it it's funny but yeah
yeah she really does not like that oh my
goodness
she well she's just informing you yeah
she's informing you still again that
it's like still on come here but she
doesn't like it come here
[Laughter]
she's like no no you're gonna be on
camera yeah what's the matter baby
she's like I don't like the fan that's
what
she's like okay relax she's like no
she's like no no fans on huh no
stands on okay
oh
uh Samantha Bee said just popped on
where is this uh this episode takes
takes place in Seattle that's where this
one is back in 2004.
all right let's see where was I
okay so yeah so she looks up and she
said that she saw like a dude she saw
like a guy like standing in the bedroom
door
um she didn't really specify like I'm
guessing that she immediately knew that
it wasn't like a person like that she
knew it was an apparition even though
she wasn't real clear about that but the
fact that she immediately like got up
and then went to like investigate the
apartment which I mean she did pick up a
weapon but you would think that if she
thought that that was a real guy then
she would have just like [ __ ]
screamed and called the cops or
something like that but so she goes like
creeping through the apartment like
looking for this dude but of course
since he's a ghost uh you know she kind
of like goes all creepily down the hall
and stuff like that and you know
obviously he's not there and
um I think that she said that she kind
of saw him go down the hall and like go
into the bathroom which is something
that um would happen a lot like with
these apparitions that they were seeing
now she did say because like I said she
was on the show like both her and Bill
were on the show and like a couple of
the Ghost Hunters were on there talking
as well so she said she's very sure that
she saw something but she didn't really
believe in ghosts so she didn't really
know like what to make of it even though
I'm the implication being that I'm
pretty sure that she thought it was a
ghost but then she's like well I
couldn't have seen that because they
don't exist or whatever
so Bill comes home later like from work
and icy is like pretty upset and she
tells him I don't know if she straight
up tells him hey I saw a guy or she
basically says
um I feel like you know we're never
alone in here that there's something in
here with us and she's like whenever I'm
here by myself I keep seeing like
shadows out of the corner of my eye and
then like when I look up they're gone
you know what I mean so I don't know if
she said like hey I saw a dude uh Bill
does not believe her at first thinking
she's
overreacting like always happens in
these [ __ ] episodes or is seeing
things because of eye strain this is one
of the parts that we were kind of
laughing at because he was kind of like
making jokes about it and she was like
dude it's not funny and you know Tom
says something like have you ever could
have you just considered you know the
possibility that you may be a woman yeah
and then you're incapable of like
perceiving reality as it is make a [ __ ]
it's all imagination and she got like
really really bad I'm like yeah like
pretty much every woman on Earth would
get mad if you like [ __ ] talk to them
like that I was laughing it was very
funny it was very I thought that you
might be a woman yeah
you don't know how things work because
you know we women our eyes don't work
our ears don't work nothing works we
don't we don't know how it is our brains
don't work you're [ __ ] crazy we don't
know how things work ever
[Laughter]
but see that's the thing it's not it's
not crazy that's just like the way it is
but I mean you know that it's not good
but it's like so you it's weird because
it's like double layered you know what I
mean like you know that it's like that
and it's like it's not good but there's
nothing you can do about it yeah you
want to know what a woman feels like
[ __ ] it take some Trend take some Trend
balloon let that [ __ ] let that Tom
would not uh recommend it no
let that progesterone [ __ ] level go
way high and I was like see it's not fun
is it not fun at all women are
clinically insane I I test I've been
there they're [ __ ] crazy but I I I I
see the insanity I understand it now I
understand it
there is a certain amount of truth to it
it's just a
you don't want to perceive things like
that all the time and I don't think they
perceive things like that all the time
it has to do with their cycle for pretty
sure
well I don't know about that because
it's kind of like you think it's
constant
well I can't speak for everybody
obviously but you know mine is pretty
much like that has always been like that
like as long as I can remember constant
lack of confidence constant checking
yourself to think that maybe you
perceived that the wrong way constantly
[ __ ] double checking and yeah and and
and and like and and it's that it's
doubly frustrating too and it's like
[ __ ] like like I make jokes about this
but [ __ ] like this doesn't help that
like every time that's why it always
like makes me laugh like in all of these
kind of like paranormal shows and like
movies and stuff where the woman is
always kind of like hey bro I saw a
ghost and everybody's like why are you
sure you saw that maybe you're just
tired maybe you're just like [ __ ] I saw
a [ __ ] ghost okay God damn it it's
like why can't you just like believe me
I don't really get it so so that's like
very frustrating for us because it
doesn't help because we already have
that inbuilt thing where we're
constantly doubting ourselves and that
it's like a horrible like feedback loop
because then you have like dudes telling
you oh well you didn't really see that
or you're crazy or something like that
and I'm like wait am I yeah now I don't
know you know what I mean so it's really
it's very it's very funny it's very
frustrating yeah I've experienced it
it's not good
and uh total lack of confidence uh
[ __ ] you
uh what else is like another oh uh
[ __ ] sentimentality insecurity
uh [ __ ]
um
over overly sentimental about [ __ ] it's
just uh no it's not good it's not good
from a man's point of view
when you have normal male [ __ ]
hormonal balance like a tank it doesn't
you're just like you're Rock Solid yeah
[ __ ] I don't care oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] and
it just you just plow through it
almost with a sense of like uh no I'm
never wrong
but there's something about being that
way that's very comfortable you're wrong
as [ __ ] but you don't care you know well
yeah sometimes you don't care yeah dudes
are totally like that yeah they don't
think they're ever wrong about anything
yeah well even though they frequently
are yeah
you could be wrong as [ __ ]
you might be partially aware that you're
wrong but you don't care
it's kind of like anesthesia
you're numb to to your own dickheadness
your own stupidity you don't yeah you're
just like bulletproof yeah which which
does give you a lot of confidence you
can get through some [ __ ] [ __ ] you
can get through some serious [ __ ] all
successful military guys are like that
pretty much well they've done lots and
lots of studies like with um you know
male and female students and what they
find like largely is that men like weigh
um like over exaggerate their
intelligence and their abilities and
things like that whereas women will win
like a lot of times they're like really
good at [ __ ] but they're not confident
enough to
you know come out and be good and a lot
of times that like hinders them a little
bit but then in another way it's like
sometimes dudes are like not really all
that smart or not really all that
capable but they think that they're
awesome in the [ __ ] so sometimes they're
like to an extent they're able to kind
of like [ __ ] their way through
things yeah like eventually they you
will get caught but you know yeah well
yeah in my experience it's better to be
overcome overconfident than than to lack
confidence your success rate will be a
lot higher if you're overconfident now
does it make you bulletproof and immune
no those dudes get killed they get
killed all the time but it doesn't
matter men are kind of disposable in the
real world which is [ __ ] fighting and
stealing things and trying to get food
and capturing territory and all that
[ __ ] caveman [ __ ] you're better off
you were selected to just be kind of
dumb
dumb and [ __ ]
overconfident because
statistically those guys tended to
reproduce so the children were like that
guys that sat around twiddled their
thumb or were overly sensitive they
didn't reproduce Two beta I'm laughing
at Ben saying it's literally true uh all
women are crazy uh even a woman who you
think is perfectly rational and stable
if you engage with them you'll find out
they believe in elves or talking trees
or portals to other worlds
don't even get started on women and
angels and magic crystals yeah yeah
but you know I don't believe in any of
that stuff yeah they're not all like
that but and actually I know some dudes
that do believe in so so yeah well [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've seen that [ __ ] Jenny's seen
things that would fall into that realm
but it's not Supernatural it it's
Quantum Consciousness I don't have any
patience
though yeah it's just reality isn't
quite as real as you think it is
uh which like yeah that's fair enough
but like I'm a very very scientifically
minded person yeah like it takes a lot
to like convince me quantum theory
explains a lot of it just look at
pembrose
and Stuart amaroff there's a lot of new
stuff that did a lot of new stuff on
YouTube
of them talking about stuff they made a
lot of discoveries the mind is a quantum
computer
you're dealing with Quantum fields and
quantum physics which can explain a lot
of these things that were formerly
believed to be paranormal they are
paranormal but they're not Supernatural
and once you get a
once you get a scientific framework to
explain these phenomena they're going on
they won't even be paranormal they'll
just be scientific
it has to do with Quantum particles and
clouds that are around you and your soul
is a real thing it's a
it's a Quantum field it's what's making
you experience kawalia which is kind of
like the sensation of being
things that a digital computer will
never be able to do
so
and when you die it could continue on
that would fit quantum physics there's
no reason because once the part once all
those particles are in superposition and
entanglement you could take the physical
brain and body away and that that
Quantum field would still hold itself
together and continue on in other words
a spirit
freaky [ __ ] but that lines up with
everything that I've [ __ ] seen in
terms of obes ndes poltergeist
phenomenon rspk
dreaming true
dream invasion
premonitions
um
and some of the [ __ ] that you see in
[ __ ] combat
because you're in a state of
with me it was always fear or
um
fight or flight instincts over a long
period of time
like Jenny's seen it when we were
writing the book took me a couple weeks
or a month or so to kind of fire up and
eventually kind of an eerie feeling came
kind of came across the house
periodically and phenomena will happen
but it's not a ghost
it's just a Quantum field and I didn't
find it particularly scary yeah it was
to me kinda I just thought it was
feeling I thought it was kind of neat
yeah well I thought it was kind of neat
because it's like I always was kind of
like oh wouldn't it be cool if that was
real and like if I could actually see it
so when I saw it I was just like ooh
you know what I mean that's cool but
it's like it didn't really scare me I
mean the only thing that would scare me
was that like I said if you got mad at
me one day and like winged a brick at my
head or something like that but well now
you said you saw you felt it watching
you and that it it it made you and you
got it for a second like after it first
happened like and I went out down the
hall into the bathroom like for a second
I felt kind of like weird and creeped
out but like other than that like it
didn't release it's a still feeling of
deep still feeling of eeriness kind of
like you're being watched
and when you said it rang the doorbell
twice I did have that feeling when I got
up that I could feel it see now that
scared me but that's because I thought
it was a person yeah
opening the garage door and [ __ ]
because I was like I don't want it to be
a [ __ ] serial killer like standing
out there like you know what I mean I
wasn't sure that's why that's why it was
scared that's what scared me
[ __ ] funny
Tonka what was that go check it out the
hand heard a gun go ahead go ahead check
it out well I mean I didn't tell you you
had to check it out I just said some
[ __ ] just rang the doorbell yeah
yeah I was like I if it was up to me I'd
have been like you know what I'm just
gonna ignore that yeah and like I'm not
even gonna go look in case somebody
[ __ ] shoots me through the glass or
some [ __ ] like that yeah because like I
said I thought it was a person no for me
which I'm absolutely not going to the
door at my age four o'clock in the
morning I haven't tried to do it since
HRT but I kind of think during HRT with
my hormone levels it probably would
happen a little faster but it took uh
what probably two or three weeks for it
to start I don't even remember at this
point we were writing a book I think it
was about two or three weeks and it
slowly kind of
ramped up started with the television
turn it on and off
finding televisions away even the
television that was in the room that we
were turned on remember yeah it was a
little stuff like that
and then uh got bigger as it went but
over a period of about a month
it's not something you can do
spontaneously it takes time to at least
at my age it takes time to start
firing it up and the main
input the main energy behind it for me
is fear fear can can get it started it
started faster
so if anybody's a student of that [ __ ]
it has something to do with fight or
flight instincts I think
something about negative emotions
so uh so yeah so where were we all right
so we were talking about uh bill being
like yeah have you considered that
you're a woman and you're not like
saying things correctly blah blah blah
now icy even said that she's like well
bill was kind of like reassuring at
first like oh it's gonna be okay yada
yada so for a little while she kind of
felt silly even though she she did feel
like she was overreacting like after he
said that even though she was like a
pretty I'm pretty sure I saw some [ __ ]
but you know what I mean you know how it
goes
um and I and she said that she still
didn't feel safe in the apartment at all
especially alone so basically they're
like she's like after class she would
just go to there was like a coffee shop
in the neighborhood and she would just
go there and sit in there like until the
evening until bill came home because she
didn't want to be in the apartment by
herself because she felt so creeped out
by it so um so she's at home one night
like she comes home
after her class and all that kind of
stuff and she's really really like
irritable and angry and she said that
she had just started to feel like Bill
wasn't really like listening to her
wasn't really taking her seriously and
she kind of resented that he didn't have
to spend that much time in the apartment
so he didn't really know what was going
on or like experience what she
experienced so that particular night she
like kind of let him have it and they
ended up like having this really really
big fight
um and that bill at this point said well
I see it really changed a lot she used
to be like really fun and outgoing and
blah blah
um but she became like really moody and
withdrawn
um the funny thing about it was like
they're having the fight and he's like I
thought we had got past that and she's
kind of like uh there's still like a
[ __ ] ghost in the apartment and it's
still like scary so I don't know I was
like well I guess he got past it because
he doesn't have to worry about it but
she's the one having to like [ __ ]
deal with it but uh yeah so she was mad
so they had like a big fight and they
actually didn't talk to each other again
until like the following evening they
said like after this big fight that they
bad but uh Bill shows up he comes home
and he's got the flowers and the whole
thing and they kind of like talk
everything out and uh you know he says
yeah I'm sorry I was we kind of laughed
too because he said yeah I was acting
like a jerk and she was like no no it
was me and blah blah he's like no it's I
was a jerk don't sugarcoat it and I'm
like oh well you don't want me to
sugarcoat it then then I'm gonna say all
kind of terrible [ __ ] but yeah so uh so
they kind of like talked it out or
anything and then it so happens that
they're like we're just gonna chill out
tonight we're just gonna like you know
just have some leftovers and watch
movies and not do any studying or
anything like that and then Bill sees
the ghost too like they're sitting on
the couch and he looks over and sees The
Apparition like standing there in the
hallway and the and it moves kind of
like down the hall toward the bathroom
and he follows it there but obviously
when he gets into the bathroom there's
nobody in there
so then like he says to icy I saw
somebody he described and this was like
the real guy he said he described it as
a tall thin dark figure and icy said
yeah that's the same thing that I saw
and then Bill tried then like literally
like five seconds like after he sees the
ghost like he's just like oh it was
nothing even though he just literally
like saw a [ __ ] person like it yeah
like a ghostly person like his oh yeah
and then she just also said it's like
that's the same [ __ ] ghost I saw oh
it was nothing it was yeah I I don't
know about that
because I never even really saw an
apparition but saw a lot of objects move
starting off in that Dam Mammoth
Mountain and just seeing objects moves
as a [ __ ] life-changing event
just to have something thrown out of a
[ __ ]
yeah I mean the fact that he could just
like immediately and I don't know if
that's how it really happened but that's
like what happened in the reenactment
just that you could actually just kind
of go oh well ghosts exists now yeah
okay yeah whatever yeah nah
I'm not really buying that
either that or maybe The Apparition
wasn't it wasn't impressive it might
have just been like a a hazy Shadow I
kind of suspect maybe that's what it was
because on the show they actually kind
of now on the show they show it as like
a person but I but honestly I don't
think at least according to the real
people that were on there being
interviewed they did say that they saw
the ghost like what the dude looked like
but not until later like that was the
impression that I got I thought that
prior to that they had just been seeing
like a shadowy sort of figure like a
shadow person but then like later on
they saw him more clearly but I could be
totally wrong about that but that was
kind of the impression that I got but on
the show they kind of made it look like
it was just like a like a ghostly
looking person like standing there
so uh so yeah it was nothing we just saw
a [ __ ] ghostly ass person so this
pisses icy right off as it would she's
like oh it's nothing okay she's like
well I'm getting the [ __ ] out of here I
don't know about you so Bill said okay
well I'll come with you too so they go
and hang out at this coffee shop like
all the rest of the evening now they
start talking to one another and they're
just like well maybe we should try and
like do something about this like they
both actually want to move out but they
can't afford it you know that happens a
lot in these uh so they go online and
they find this place the Washington
State ghost Society
and they get in touch with this woman
named Shannon stidman now I looked her
up she actually has an IMDb page and
this all it says on the IMDb page
um says Shannon stidman now makes her
home in Austin she is no longer a ghost
hunter but keeps in touch with icy
Spencer she quit ghost hunting because
she lost faith but she does continue to
keep in touch with some of the people
she worked with in a ghost ages that was
like a thing she was in and the
Washington State ghost Society so that's
all this is just like a little I've
never seen an IMDb page like that but it
just had like a little paragraph on it
where I don't know so just you know just
I was looking up all the people on here
to see if there was any [ __ ] and that
was like the only outside [ __ ] I could
find
so Shannon pretty much advises them as
she said that she did to all of the
people that contacted her she's like
just basically keep a log of everything
that happens and just if anything starts
getting worse or escalating like just
keep checking in with us and telling us
when new [ __ ] happens and then like if
it starts getting bad then we'll come
there and like see if it warrants an
investigation or whatever she said
because she wanted to make sure that
you know she's like because we get
messages all the time
from people and then like later on they
find out it wasn't Supernatural or
nothing else happened or something like
that so she's like we can't just go
investigate everything so they have to
like make sure that there's actually
something they're worth investigating
so so after they contacted her though
they said the month after that was like
much quieter they said for a while they
said they didn't really feel the
presence in the apartment at all like
the way they did before I'm not really
sure like what the explanation for that
was they didn't really seem to have an
idea
but then there's like one night when
they're kind of sitting on the living
room floor like playing cards or
whatever and then icy sees the ghost
again like the dude in the hallway and
then Bill also turns around and sees it
so they both see it at the same time now
icy like flips out and she like shouts
at it to leave like get that this is our
house like get out of here
um it goes into the bathroom again and
then bill goes in after it now he
doesn't see anything at first but then
like he's looking in the mirror and he
sees the ghost like standing in the tub
like but in the mirror like when he
turns around and looks at the actual tub
like he doesn't see it so at this point
he said he did see it's he did see its
face like she he saw what it looked like
and he said it looked like a young man
like a boy like a teenage kid he said he
looked about 17. and he said that his
face looked what he called severely
damaged like his face was kind of on the
show it was just kind of like bloody
like on the side of his face
but he said he was just back there like
begging not to be killed like don't kill
me don't kill me like that somebody he
just like saw him in the mirror now Bill
said that he got the idea like the
feeling that this ghost wasn't evil and
was just like trying to tell them
something or like ask them for help but
icy is like not having it she's like
well it's still creepy and I still don't
want it in the house like I don't care
if it's [ __ ] friendly or not
um so yeah so she said at this point she
was feeling like really desperate and
trapped she really wanted to move and
they couldn't and you know she's like I
said trying not to spend like as very
much time in this apartment because it
was like freaking around
so one night she's home alone studying
and she hears and I guess Bill is not
home but she's kind of like she hears a
door open in the apartment at least
that's what it sounded like she so she
thinks bill came home without her
knowing and she calls to him but there
isn't any answer so then after a minute
though like she's reading and like a
shadow Falls over her book and then she
turns and she sees another Apparition
now this one doesn't look like the dude
from before this one looks like a big
intimidating shadow person rather than
the teenager that they had been seeing
um at this point like I see nopes the
[ __ ] out
um and she like runs over to pound on
the door like the manager next door and
then like the manager like opens up and
then starts laughing maniacally and then
Psych the whole thing was a dream so you
know what I mean and then like to
justify it I love that they had like a
little snippet of interview with the
real icy where she says I was living in
a nightmare and I'm like okay
so I don't know if she actually really
saw that because they made it seem like
she really did see that but then they
showed that it was just a dream
uh yeah icy also said that the apartment
felt like a huge Crypt which I thought
was an interesting thing to say
so it's been two months since they moved
in so it's December
um and icy has kind of like Fallen apart
they said she wasn't really taking care
of herself she's not really speaking to
her friends anymore she's failing like a
bunch of her classes
um she said she felt like she was under
a spell like she was turning into
someone else and had also was very very
depressed and had actually like
considered self-harm things of that
nature
so that night icy gets home late because
she's been trying not to hang out in the
apartment and Bill freaks out because he
was like worried about her he didn't
know where she was and then they both
see like a really scary ghost dude this
looks like a dude but it's clearly not
the same dude he basically looks like um
a dude from like [ __ ] Goodfellas or
something like that but like not as well
dressed he looks like a you know what I
mean he like Chazz palmitary or
something like that he looks like
somebody like that like a like a big
thug
so he walks down the hall and they both
follow them but then the ghost does this
gesture thing like he goes to the end of
the hall and then turns around like hey
you Goombas like that kind of thing and
then he goes kind of like that or
something I don't I couldn't tell what
he was doing like it looked like he was
going hey look at sorta but then like
there's like a white light like a white
stick type situation and then Bill said
they showed him like pulling his shirt
up because he was like oh my chest by
chest and then like he pulls his shirt
up and there's like a like a wound there
like right between his uh little little
man little moves there what man boobs he
didn't have boobs because he was very
skinny okay but it's time I I'm gonna go
up you're gonna turn the thing off yeah
okay
the other alarm has gone up uh yeah so
basically so I think they made it look
like more dramatic for the show because
like I said it looked like somebody had
like kind of sliced like he'd had like
open heart surgery or some [ __ ] like
that but he all he said was that it felt
like someone had put out a lit cigarette
like on his chest which is painful sure
but I don't think it's like like having
your chest placed open like they showed
on the thing but whatever
so at this point
um the couple are both like uh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and they get the [ __ ] out and they
go and stay in a motel
and then they contact the Ghost Hunters
again and were like yeah yeah you guys
need to get here because like shit's
getting like really really bad we've now
we saw another ghost and this ghost is
um it's like kicking our ass
so Shannon like the ghost hunter lady
she comes to the motel to meet with them
and she's like yeah it definitely seems
like your situation might be uh becoming
dangerous at this point because like
this other ghost like actually you know
hurt you and um said okay well we're
gonna come and like intervene and see
what we can do about it so she basically
says and this is something they say on a
lot of the um episodes that probably the
ghost was stirred up by all the
renovations they did because remember
they said they renovated the whole
apartment like before they moved in she
also thought that maybe
the spirits were feeding off the
couple's fear uh and the conflicts they
were having with one another over you
know over a bit like being in this bad
situation and like fighting all the time
about how like you know icy didn't want
to be there and stuff like that
so the ghost hunting team say they're
gonna go check out the apartment
um now at first IC is like absolutely
not I'm not going back there but um
Shannon is like well you have to be
there in case the investigators have
have to ask you some [ __ ] so AC said
well okay I'll go but I'm not going
inside I'm like gonna stand my ass out
in the parking lot so if that's how
that's gonna go
so a few hours later uh the ghost
hunting team shows up and with them they
have a medium named Lois Lee uh the real
person of which was also on the show
now reportedly as they're supposed to do
they supposedly did not tell this medium
psychic lady anything about what had
been going on prior like anything about
any of the apparitions that ain't even
seen or anything like that and they also
told Bill and icy don't talk to her
until after she goes in there and checks
everything out so we can make sure that
you're not like tainting her data or
whatever
so Lois goes in there and starts doing
her thing where she's kind of like
feeling around the walls and objects and
stuff and she said an interesting thing
she said when she first went in there
she said
um that she didn't feel anything at all
initially she said that normally when
she goes in a place that's supposedly
haunted like she can feel it immediately
you know that there's something in there
like a presence but she said she didn't
feel anything like in this place not
like not at all but then she goes into
the bathroom
and apparently sees or has a vision of
of the young man in the bathtub who's
like crying don't kill me don't kill me
and she said that she felt like really
sorry for him and she initially says hey
I'm not going to hurt you but then she
said it felt like
she was
um like like taking the place of another
person or that there was like another
person
I don't know like necessarily possessing
her or anything like that but she was
like in the position of someone else who
was looking at this like and threatening
and menacing this kid and so she finds
herself like approaching the young man
with her hand raised and she said she
could feel a gun in her hand
she also said that she had like a really
really gory Vision it seemed like that
she said just like blood splattered
everywhere and stuff like all over the
room like in the vision and she smelled
something really really horrible and
then she said like the next thing she
knew she was running out of the
apartment and then she just like puked
all over the parking lot
uh and she said that she had never felt
anything like that before and that this
was like bad news this is like a really
bad situation
so her hypothesis and we'll get into
this is that this was some kind of this
was the impression that she got that
this was some kind of drug or Gang
Related retribution killing now although
this neighborhood apparently used to be
known for that sort of thing um I guess
it's kind of like not like that anymore
now evidently
I'm assuming if they found a case that
corresponded with you know what the
people were seeing in the apartment then
they absolutely would have trumpeted
that like on the show
so the fact that they didn't find that
if they didn't say that like leads me to
believe that there wasn't a crime that
had occurred like that
um in that I mean but it might have
occurred somewhere else in the building
or somewhere else in the neighborhood
that's I think that's what Danny was
saying earlier about you know why did
why is this kid haunting this place if
like he didn't even get killed there and
yeah that seems to be the thing because
nobody seems to think that this actually
happened there because I think they were
trying to imply that it happened there
like with all the stuff that they said
at the beginning about like the
apartment manager saying oh well the
Last Tenant left in a hurry and left it
like kind of a mess you know which would
imply oh left in a hurry like got killed
and you know somebody got murdered in
there so it was like blood and brain
matter all over the walls that they had
to clean up you know what I mean so I
kind of feel like that's what they were
getting at but they're as far as I know
there isn't any proof that
anything like that happened at least in
that particular apartment I don't know
about and honestly I couldn't find the
address of this like I didn't have a
huge amount of time to like to look for
it but sometimes like on some of the
episodes it's pretty easy like to find
at least the street that the real house
is on but this one I couldn't really
um find anything about it so I don't
know like I said if they had found
anything corresponding to what they were
seeing in the apartment I'm sure they
would have said on the show and they
didn't so I'm assuming that nothing like
that happened in defense of the case
I don't think to see an apparition or to
make contact
with a disembodied soul I don't think
you have to actually be in the location
where the person killed it one just has
to contact you yeah you have to come
into into its
into its uh uh awareness and in my
content I mean that might have been
somebody killed in that area but maybe
not in that house or maybe there's maybe
ICC in this guy and he may have had some
kind of connection to her family or
something in a weird way and she didn't
quite know the connection it may have
been something like that I don't it
didn't have to happen in that apartment
really
this is psychic phenomenon you're
you're soul is coming in contact
with a disembodied soul and it's trying
to pass you a message you might see it
or believe you see it with your eyes but
you may not be seeing it with your eyes
and maybe seeing it with your mind and
soul
like you know if you take a picture like
there he is and you would take a picture
there'd probably be nothing in that
picture
so I'm not going to say it's a
hallucination
but it's a it's a it's a hallucinatory
type thing but it doesn't mean that that
Soul isn't contacting you you know
it might be strong enough to where you
could actually see it but it's probably
not there it's in another dimension
interestingly though it does kind of
seem like
this is what it's like I said I don't
know if I believe any of this kind of
stuff or anything like that but this
does seem more like a residual residual
yeah because it seemed like they always
saw when they saw this Apparition or at
least in the reenactments it seemed like
it was always going in the bathroom and
like people saw it like in the tub like
don't kill me like at the moment of the
trauma or the moment of the death or
whatever so it almost seemed like
something that was like replaying rather
than somebody that was trying to like
communicate seeing Beyond the Veil or
whatever yeah see in the past so maybe
that's what it was maybe it was just
kind of like maybe something bad did
happen well like I said it was an
apartment building so maybe it was like
somewhere else in the building who
[ __ ] knows and like I said to
somebody who worked in the building
right maybe something like that yeah
like I said it's all hypothetical
[ __ ] and it could you know it's like Mr
Halloran says you know it's just like
burned toast sometimes you know
something bad happens and it leaves
something behind but you're dealing with
another dimension it might have left
something behind in a distant look
location but you're already outside
you're already in an in another
dimension so that just because it
happened far away doesn't mean you can't
access it or it can't access you
it's just
you'd have to see it it's the spirit
world
spirit world could get you creature and
touch no matter where you are you might
just be receptive to it so you're kind
of chosen or you accessed it
it doesn't necessarily mean it was in
that physical location right you know
it's just that sometimes I kind of feel
like they're trying to make it seem like
that yeah you know what I mean because
like some of the episodes they'll be
like oh we saw like this old lady ghost
and then we found out oh that this [ __ ]
old lady used to live here and she was
an Ax Murderer whatever the [ __ ] you
know what I mean look they always want
to tie [ __ ] to a location because that's
a very human thing to do it must be here
but you're not the spirit world doesn't
work that way
you're seeing something across time well
[ __ ] if you can see something across
time space is nothing
so not only is seeing something across
time you're seeing something across the
space space time isn't that relevant
with this you know for some reason you
dialed up a number and saw something
that happened somewhere else a long time
ago didn't have anything to do with
where you were
and maybe it's a complete anomaly
because like you said sometimes it
happens and I don't know like I said I
don't know where this particular
apartment is so I don't really know
because after all this I think they only
lived in the apartment for a couple of
months and they said [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
get it they got out because like the
ghost hunting team were like well we
would advise you like not to stay here
because it seems like it's escalating
and it might actually get dangerous
because it looks like it can actually
hurt you so they moved yeah not to say
that all of them aren't location based I
think some of the stories that are told
and what they're saying it may have been
something based in that location but
you're limited to limiting yourself if
you think it's always location based
it's like radio
or television you could see that [ __ ]
movie no matter where you were you just
turn the TV on yeah you tune it in
you're tuned it in right you're now
seeing something
that happened a long time ago to
somebody else in another place but you
called it you dialed that phone number
you put it on that channel you saw it
well maybe you accidentally did that
yeah just accidentally exactly yeah it
could just be like random exactly it's
like random which might explain like I
said why sometimes like people see [ __ ]
in a house and then they move out and
other people move in and nobody don't
see anything in there ever again because
maybe it has to do with like the person
like the receiver right you know it's
psychic phenomena it's like telepathy
you know you've created a psychic link
with something that was around a long
time ago in another place and somehow
you got links to it and you saw it
so
I'm not real
I'm not really impressed by
location-based stuff because Poltergeist
phenomena didn't care about anything
about location wherever you were that's
where it was
you know Mammoth yeah
Lois's house uh my house or it's
actually my mom's house or her apartment
in those days and then anywhere where I
[ __ ] start firing it up it'll take
time it'll happen
so location has nothing to do with it
yes and who knows you might be able to
bring something through
something you don't want I always
worried about that you know what I mean
uh or you might manifest something or
create something you can't control you
know
that was really like you know Jenny see
some weird [ __ ] you know the [ __ ]
pile of coins appearing at my feet and
everything well my hair was standing up
I could feel it stand up on the back my
neck after that remote got thrown and I
felt like I was going to lose control of
it
you know because once fear starts going
it gets bigger well what's going to
happen million are you going to invent
some kind of monster and it
it manifests itself you know psychic
monster or something you know it's
invisible but it just throws things it
breaks things
you know
and it might slip out of your control
kind of like a character in one of your
dreams or what if something evil
sees that in another dimension and goes
oh I know how to use this and then
hijacks it
it's like oh I'm gonna go yeah energy
source right this is an energy source
and I'm going to use this guy and then
you might actually bring in a [ __ ]
dead person that was bad or something
kind of like a demon something that has
never lived just some kind of a creature
that lives in the astral plane if that's
what you want to call her lives in that
other dimension and it's like something
from that movie from Beyond you know
remember the little fish things they're
flying no no you don't know because it's
I had that out of body experience and
there's a lot of stuff over there
it's mostly peaceful though mostly empty
space
but I was aware of
kind of like a cosmic Consciousness that
there's a lot of stuff out there there
are things that were never human out
there
but they're not necessarily bad a lot of
the bad stuff was from my understanding
of what it felt like is that a lot of
the bad stuff was weak
wasn't strong enough to do very much
Danny says the possessed mom driving
episode was a good one yeah that was
actually one of the ones we were
considering doing because we watched it
like a couple weeks ago but we'll
probably get around to that one yeah
that scene where she was driving the kid
and like staring at the kid while she
was then driving ahead that was like one
of the creepiest things it was ever on
that's just her expression like was so
[ __ ] creepy uh Danny also said in the
episode with the female cop Ghost Hunter
who got her son possessed episode was
good yeah I think that one's just called
The Ghost Hunter right that was another
one that uh we should probably do one of
these days but yeah I mean that was like
pretty much the end of the story like I
said the Spencer's like got moved the
[ __ ] out of the apartment and moved to
another place like also in Seattle and
they said it was like much much nicer
and I don't know what happened to him
again after that so that was like uh
pretty much it you know yeah it's decent
it's a decent story it was yeah and like
I said there was it was a lot more like
Apparition heavy than yeah some of the
other ones but I don't know there was
something about it I kind of liked
something may have happened there I
don't know but you know don't know
exactly what it was but something could
have happened there I'm not gonna just
dismiss it out of hand
I just I think what I what I felt was
funny about it was like all the
arguments that you had about like curves
like I don't know why that made me laugh
so much because it just seems like it's
such a truth or being a woman it's a
yeah it's like such a Trope like in so
many of these that it's almost kind of
like a thing where yeah you know because
the girl always sees it first yeah
almost always like I like when they do
exceptions to it too because there are
some exceptions but
even when he saw it he was still trying
to like dismiss it yeah that's what I'm
thinking I think I think the guys see it
too but I think they don't admit to
themselves that they saw it
because the first thing that I saw
was my little handbag turned on inside
and I could have swore that I saw all
those those socks
rolling across the bed and it has come
to a screeching halt and I went no that
didn't happen I immediately nope no it
just fell over that's what I was
thinking but no it was
going through my bag well I think and
we've kind of touched on this before and
actually one guy that one real guy that
was like interviewed on a haunting that
had one of these experiences like almost
said this word for word is that I think
guys have a harder time because they
don't like they like dudes in general
they kind of want to like fix something
yeah and this is something that you
can't really fix you can't really do
anything about it okay you grab it you
can't fight it you can't punch it you
can't like one guy even said that you
can't punch it like what are you
supposed to do like and they feel kind
of like helpless because it's like well
you know I can't I want to like you know
protect my wife and kids or you know fix
the problem and I can't fix the problem
because it's like too amorphous and I
think that really bothers them so a lot
of times they're just kind of like nope
it's not happening yeah so they just go
in it
you could have an M16 you couldn't shoot
it that's what I'm saying like you can't
yeah like there's no solution yeah my
boy here from [ __ ] hunting into in
Daytona Deltona time
he said the same thing as the next Army
Ranger and he says he just he would try
to fight it and it would get worse
but there's nothing you can do you can't
grab it you can't
beat on it you can't you can't hide from
it
um it can be watching you
you can feel it watching you you don't
see it but you can feel it you know it's
in there and there's nothing you can do
about it yeah you know and maybe that's
harder I kind of feel like that's at
least the dudes that have been on the
show like talking about it it does seem
like harder for them to deal with yeah
that they can't like yeah I was a kid
when it was going on so it's easier for
me to just [ __ ] relent go yeah yeah
this is this yeah this is bad well yeah
because you didn't have any like Risk
but you didn't feel like you had any
responsibility to like fix it or like do
something about it because adults around
me to try to protect me you know yeah
[ __ ] I was just going oh yeah this is
bad
it's like something out of the damn a
[ __ ] horror movie you know and it's
real it's weird yeah it's really weird
so all this stuff I Saw The Apparition
but ads okay uh that's not my experience
like I said I don't really know I mean I
could believe it because the real guy
was on they're being interviewed and
he's not been impressive yeah that's
what I'm saying it either wasn't that
impressive or the dude was like so far
in denial that he was just kind of like
no I didn't see it like he was just
trying to make himself feel better now
when you see it for real
first thing I saw was Poltergeist
and it becomes undeniable it's
life-changing you're you go into shock
you're like no this can't be you're
going to denial and [ __ ] my uncle rep is
in denial he was trying to pull the
[ __ ] carpet up he thought there must
have been some kind of a hidden [ __ ]
doors in the floors and somebody coming
up you know just but the things you're
seeing just couldn't be done by a
physical person
you know
so you just have to go no this is
something invisible this must be a ghost
because that's the only explanation it
must be a ghost yeah yeah
and that's what it was though I thought
it wasn't that at the time but looking
back I don't think but like I said it
was like right people didn't know as
much about Poltergeist back then or at
least it wasn't hadn't been like
disseminated like widely now everybody
knows but yeah you couldn't find the
information back then now everybody
knows yeah all right so are you ready to
wrap it up seems like you're gonna go
down down there and get to get that
Carnitas rolling yeah you want Taco
uh sure okay maybe maybe a couple okay
that'd be really good I'm gonna go Brown
that meat let me go Brown that meat
all right all right uh thanks you guys
for dropping by on this haunting Mondays
I hope you guys enjoyed it uh tomorrow
we are gonna be back uh same time and
we're gonna do a matinee and we're gonna
be talking about platoon which uh was
the other movie that Louie sent us so
we're gonna watch that tonight and we
will do a discussion on that tomorrow on
a live stream so hopefully you guys can
uh come for that so thanks for hanging
out with us this evening and we'll see
you guys again tomorrow good